[Music]
you
during this election
you
there I am oh my goodness could people
not hear me that entire time
I think I've just been ranting for about
two minutes and nobody could hear me
nobody could hear me beautiful yeah we
had a there was a technical issue which
there was an element of tech that we had
to fix very very strong yes now okay let
me take it from the top in fact this is
good because I said things I really
regretted during those 90 seconds and
I'm glad to be able to to get it back we
are standing by for a Kayleigh McKenna
knee press briefing at the top of the
hour we had a stream that wrapped up
last night around 11:00 p.m. Eastern and
we are indeed back I had Stephen Kenneth
destiny bunnell the second on the show
last night and we are if you miss that
I'm uploading it separately to YouTube
at 3:00 p.m. Eastern Time so in about 70
minutes so you're gonna be able to see
that and Kaylee McKenna knee has already
unleashed some whoppers on us today I'm
going to get to those momentarily we
have a super chat available we have all
of these different things a couple super
chat messages have come in already Mart
Fillion said instead of playing Where's
Waldo let's play where's pouchy those
books would sell like crazy
yeah foul she's missing he isn't he
isn't I mean he was interviewed
yesterday and said that this that
coronavirus is his worst nightmare and
it may only just be beginning so we did
hear from him but we're not seeing him
very much Matt Chavez says police
filming slash Miranda rights did you
look at those yet no I didn't know it's
only been 12 hours or 14 hours since the
last stream eight of which I spent
sleeping and I've been filming stuff all
day so I have not looked at that yet
okay thank you to Joe in a box and Axia
Rex and quill Aryan for the twitch
subscriptions and let's get right into
some of the meat that has been going on
earlier I was looking at some clips from
Fox News at one point I thought that Fox
News messed up therefore shot and
included the same person two times
but it turns out that this right here is
Ainsley Earhardt and over on the right
is Kaylee maghen Annie but what matters
is not how she looks but rather what she
said here is Kaylee doubling down on
Trump's conspiratorial attacks on the 75
year old protestor Martin Gugino and
let's take a listen to what she had to
say yesterday the president Kaylie was a
tweeted out that this Buffalo protested
the 75 year old who was shoved to the
ground by a police officer might have
been part of Antipa and a provocateur in
order to get that type of reaction just
to paraphrase could you expand on that
does the president think that this this
guy is part of an Tifa so the president
was raising questions so there it is
does the president think the guy is part
of an Tifa the president was raising
questions really break it down based on
a report that he saw based on a report
he saw from a former sputnik reporter
who now works for trash network Oh a n
okay are there questions that need to be
asked they're not really questions that
need to be asked actually in every case
we can't jump on one side nobody's
jumping on a side when it's all clearly
on video and an elderly man was knocked
over and bled from his ear without
looking at all the facts that play this
individual had some very questionable
tweets tweets don't make it okay we have
something called the First Amendment
here tweets that are questionable would
have been impossible for those Buffalo
police officers to know about at the
time and wouldn't justify what happened
to Martin Gugino so understand that this
is a Gish gallop she's told five lies or
distortions in 33 seconds some
profanity-laden tweets profanity also
the cops wouldn't have known that those
tweets existed and those tweets wouldn't
justify treating Martin Gugino how he
was treated about police officers of
course no one condones any sort of
violence we know it you're sort of
condoning it if the person has tweeted
profanity in a sense the appropriate
amount of force used in any interaction
there are a lot of questions in that
case
in fact you had 56 police officers who
resigned in protest yeah those police
officers are all disgusting they're
fellow officers were treated so I think
we need to ask why those officers
resigned what happened what facts were
on the ground I mean the president was
just raising some of those questions yes
so this is a total trash just like this
completely disgusting answer and so
she's clearly doubling down on it and I
would expect questions about that during
today's press briefing and it's it's
truly sick that that this is the
approach that they are taking it is
stunning and and really incredible let
me see if I had anything else from
Twitter
this was our stream last night Bernie
Sanders not in favor of defunding the
police okay we play this okay so I think
we're basically caught up from the
standpoint of Twitter Donald Trump
triggered earlier said incredible Fox
News just took congressional hearing off
the air just prior to important witness
statements more like CNN Fox's loss so
you know most presidents don't have time
nor an interest in guiding programming
on cable news Donald Trump is of course
different than other presidents and that
is indeed what he is doing so just a
wild wild time that we live in hound dog
sends a super chat saying Fed policy
update at 2:00 and Jerome pres Powell
press conference at 2:30 should be
interesting to see how markets react yes
very much looking forward to that and I
want to say a big thank you to Yvonne
chambers who just grabbed the membership
at join pakman.com thanks Yvonne Yvonne
is new member number one today on my web
site very much appreciate it I want to
talk a little bit about coronavirus
because I have a story coming up on the
program today I've already filmed it
it's in the editing phase right now
about the power the agenda-setting power
of corporate media and it we sometimes
talk about how does corporate media
affect what we think about certain
issues but today I
talk about how corporate media affects
what we think about and understand that
with coronavirus we're still in the
middle of a pandemic but the amount of
coronavirus coverage has been diminished
drastically part of it is because Donald
Trump simply decided we're not doing
briefings anymore we're basically not
going to talk about coronavirus anymore
even though we have no treatment even
though we have no vaccine even though
it's still spreading like wildfire in
some new hot spots that were not
hotspots originally and so what I want
us to think about is why aren't we
hearing about it and it's not because
the pandemic is over so let's look at
some of the charts as you can see there
is definitely I mean listen if you look
at the seven day moving average
certainly it is lower than it was the
moving average was much higher in early
April than it is now but instead of
finding 25 to 35 thousand cases a day
we're still finding 19 to 25,000 cases a
day like to say that the pandemic is
over because there's only 22,000 cases a
day on average
instead of 35,000 cases is insane and
it's what has happened and this is the
agenda setting power of corporate media
combined with Donald Trump pointing to
other things saying look elsewhere and
Tifa defund the police you know all of
this other stuff when we look at active
cases we essentially have as many active
cases right now as we ever did I mean by
a very small margin we're basically
where we were at the end of May the
pandemic is huge right now and we're
hearing less and less about it when you
look at deaths the decline is certainly
good it's up and down and we we like to
see this but you know look at yesterday
1,100 people still died and fortunately
the moving average is declining but that
could dramatically change as states
start to get overwhelmed now case in
point look at some of the places that
now regularly have the most cases so
California has had a problem since day
one and they seem unable to get it under
control
Texas and Florida though are places that
did not have early widespread cases they
started opening relatively early and
very quietly they
become hot spots look at Texas this is
the opposite of what you want to see we
we have if you look at the moving
average it's getting worse and worse
Texas is getting worse and worse we're
barely hearing anything about it Texas
regularly now with over 1,500 to 2,000
cases a day look at Florida again
Florida opening relatively early you
look at the moving average they had this
in-between period during which cases
went down now full full disclosure
Florida was caught lying about cases
cases and deaths so is this was this
even a real decline or was this just
when they were lying I don't know but
certainly record high numbers in Florida
again so the point is for whatever
reason and we know what the reasons are
right Trump's misdirection corporate
media tends to have a short attention
span relatively short attention span now
it's like coronavirus isn't going on
anymore but we're actually in the midst
of the pandemic one other thing on this
certainly there are countries that are
rapidly becoming the epicenters one of
those places is Brazil I want to see how
Russia is doing India is another one if
we look at the trend line in Brazil it's
absolutely crazy they now are at the
30,000 new cases a day pretty regularly
they may soon get very much beyond it
the death numbers are also looking very
bad in Brazil over in Russia also not
looking good I think they've started
don't know they really haven't they've
maybe peaked Russia's reopening a bunch
of stuff today that's going to be an
absolute disaster and then India also
struggling and as you can see that is
not the type of curve that you want to
see so anticipating really really ugly
stuff in India the death the death curve
already looks very very bad and it could
explode and we will see where the United
States is one week from now I hope that
it doesn't get dramatically worse but
remember everybody not everybody trump
is acting as if it's all solved when it
is not solved it is very very far from
solved thanks to Joe Graham for signing
up on YouTube I also want to say thank
you to Musashi sue who has grabbed a
twitch Prime subscription at twitch.tv
slash David Pakman two ways to get your
mess
to me most effectively if you're
watching on YouTube and you send a super
chat that's the dollar sign at the
bottom of the chat window or overlaid if
you're watching on mobile you send a
super chat your message will appear in
the lower left of the screen over there
and if you sign up on Twitch and include
some kind of message it'll show up in
that vertical blue box right above me
let me refresh this feed as we have not
it doesn't always start right away we'll
keep an eye on both of these and keep
the volume up so that we don't miss a
second of today's a press briefing
because I I certainly don't want to miss
a second of it I expect it will be short
I expect it will be extremely
propagandistic but likely not not super
long as has been the case let's see here
oh the next David Pakman show chess
tournament has been scheduled I want to
invite all of you to participate in the
first press in the first chess
tournament we had about 500 participants
I would love to blow past that Tuesday
this coming Tuesday June 16 8 p.m.
Eastern okay everybody can play it's
free you don't need to be a member all
skill levels welcome the tournament will
be on Leach s org that's Li Ches org you
can make an account now or Tuesday I
will stream my participation but please
play please play the more the merrier
and that is once again Tuesday marketing
your calendar Tuesday 8 p.m. Eastern
Time
June 16 and we are going to have a grand
old time Arun Mehta says hashtag Boris
has failed Britain on coronavirus I
believe so
Alex Stevenson says still on for
Friday's hair appointment yeah I'm still
scheduled to get a haircut on Friday and
unless unless there are dramatic changes
then we will it will be a very very
different me that shows back up here on
Monday and our opportunity for the man
bun is diminishing quickly so I'll say
it again if we get to 25 members and
patrons today I will wear the man bun
on the next stream which will probably
be tomorrow that will probably be the
last opportunity before the haircut so
it's just something I'm throwing out
there but what will i stream my haircut
probably not probably I don't think I
will I don't think I'm gonna stream my
haircut but in all seriousness are
everything we do is mostly funded by
memberships just people who go to my
website and grab a membership it's
really cheap you get a bunch of great
extra content you get the show earlier
and without commercials every single day
the commercial free podcast all of this
stuff so my invite to you is aside from
your preferences on man-bun go to join
pakman.com that code 2020 now chops 66%
off the cost of a membership I mean just
aggressively chops it right off no
questions asked and I will thank every
single person on stream who grabs a
membership today but in addition to that
if indeed we get to our goal of 25
members tomorrow I will be here in two
with a man bun in tow I think is the way
that I would say it and some people
won't like that some people won't like
that but we're it I think we will
survive it all together and that is a
that is a beautiful beautiful thing
thanks to keep rolling rolling yo for
the support over on Twitch I appreciate
that
oh the get ajob trolls are here I love
that one of my favorite attack messages
I get is please go and get a real job
and you know I get that some people
might be jealous that this is my job but
we have fortunately a business that has
been sustainable for years now thanks to
people's support and we employ people we
have office space we have you know a
lawyer and an accountant this is my job
and trust me I know that I'm fortunate
for that to be the case but that's one
of my favorite attacks that people send
please go and get a real job and I know
that what they mean is they don't like
their job and I feel for them when
that's the case but this is my job and
we are we are generate
other jobs as we now employ people which
is great
a mr. syncope says via super chat we
want to vote on the haircut I don't know
that I'm leaving the haircut subject to
a vote you know how they say you don't
want to just put civil-rights up to a
vote because sometimes people vote
against civil rights I don't know
whether that I want to put my haircut up
to a vote
I don't know that that is particularly
thrilling for me so I think we're gonna
leave it I'm gonna leave it up to me to
decide and really it's just going to be
based on safety I did see a study today
which said that there's some salon in
the Midwest somewhere that reopened with
masks for everybody everybody's wearing
masks and somebody got the virus not at
the salon but we learned they were at
the salon at the time that they had the
virus nobody else got it the full
two-week isolation period has gone by
for everybody who was exposed everybody
at the salon was wearing masks and and
no but nobody got the virus so that's a
good sign that's a good sign and that
makes me a little more confident about
going ahead and getting that haircut on
Friday as it is currently scheduled so
we'll see how it all goes okay other
things that I hold on I had a couple of
other clips I wanted to play for you but
I did not pull them up let me grab them
and you kit Patil says how do these
press briefings get progressively more
annoying they do I find them
increasingly annoying you're absolutely
right
Alan sack says I don't like my job but
it's not the fault of the David Pakman
show beautifully said beautifully said
and Daniel Huberman says what are your
thoughts on the right wing talking point
that police brutality is happening in
Democratic controlled cities so
Democrats are to blame so this is an old
talking point this is like all the
cities with the most crime are run by
Democrats cities are more democratic
than rural areas and where you have
people is where you basically have
everything you have more poverty where
there is more population density you
have more crime when there is more
population density it's it's uh it's
it's a pretty big straw man actually
to make that case and I've heard that
argument many many times thanks to
Amanda Abbott Amanda is new member
number two today at join pakman.com
appreciate your support Amanda very very
much
let me grab these other clips that I
wanted to pull up for you where is it oh
yeah I I guess I don't want to get
demonetised so I'm not gonna play the
oen story right now but I will do the
Hannity stuff
Hanna deep was promoting uh-oh the
stream just died look at that let's
reboot see what happened oh there we go
we're back so Sean Hannity was promoting
specific guns on his program last night
check this out
it's that the police could do take a
look at your screen look at that highway
no fan the financial interest in burn a
gun but I purchased the number though
yes full price I paid now I met with
them there and I purchased the number of
their items now again this is a an
alternative it won't kill people
non-lethal defense non-lethal it shoots
small projectiles filled with pepper
spray tear gas now remember tear gas was
actually outlawed in international
warfare in 1993 and the United States
ratified that in 1997 and yet tear gas
is widely used for crowd control in the
United States by police it's not allowed
in international warfare for 27 years
by the way unlike these stun guns which
have an incredibly short range and those
stupid wires this weapons accurate up to
50 feet why because I own one and even
come equipped with lasers so you can't
really miss for accuracy right now we
didn't show the video I wanted to we'll
get it up later in the show we're
actually will play for you what happens
when it wouldn't eat somebody gets it
with it yeah they don't die oh and say
it could hopefully be an alternative in
a very now remember that you can have
you can actually die from complications
related to tear gas and pepper spray it
can cause respiratory illness there are
all sorts of horrible stories and my
main takeaway from all of this is that
the instinct of these people on the
right is always to figure out like what
tool or weapon can we use rather than
how can we de-escalate situations to
begin with like our instinct our
priority our immediate response should
be
how can we deescalate these situations
altogether so you don't need to figure
out which of these weapons are is the
appropriate weapon and that's never
their instinct and again he's wrong that
these pepper spray and tear gas bullets
are harmless and he is also just
straight-up misguided when it comes to
you know these are things that are
banned in international warfare and yet
they are regularly used here in the
United States by police it's just vile
it's vile vile ok Matias Germany says do
you think Trump could quit before the
election no I don't see it I don't see
it Bryan Holaday says do you think that
the black lives matter protest can be a
catalyst for larger federal legislation
like Medicare for all green new deal etc
I hope so I hope that they actually do
achieve legislative change yes Janelle
says I can't find the yearly paid
subscription on the membership page you
just switched to yearly it's really easy
I can pull it up for you let me see join
pakman.com so when you go to my website
you just go to yearly there it is that's
all monthly yearly this is it's the same
on mobile monthly yearly monthly yearly
monthly yearly if I do yearly and hit
the sign up button and then I type in
the coupon code 2020 now $60 a year as
you will see Biko actually you know what
I'm logged in in a certain way where
this will not work let me well in any
case the coupon code works and people
are certainly using it that that
backfired because of how I'm logged in
but yeah it's there's just a button
there to go from monthly to yearly okay
other super chats coming in ridicule
says thoughts on Mark eves versus
Kennedy situation I don't know if you
have something specific that you want me
to address I mean I don't I've really
not been following it as much as I
should and I'm going to get up to speed
on it I'm hoping this weekend because it
is a very interesting race happening
here where Congressman Joe Kennedy is
running against
senator Ed Markey in the Senate race and
I think it will be a very very
interesting race and my I haven't seen
the debate yet but I heard that the
debate got pretty wacky let me say thank
you to Debbie bro who is new member
number three today at join pakman.com
and Robert Gregoire is new member number
four today at join pakman.com very much
appreciate it let me get myself properly
logged in here to the website just so I
can manipulate all elements accurately
which is always what we want here we go
bing-bang-boom
okay all right we're good okay excellent
all right we're standing by for Kayleigh
mckenna nee scheduled for 10 minutes ago
hopefully starting soon I want to say
thank you to cryptocat as well as
Martin's memory for the support on our
twitch channel we had a big big night on
Twitch last night where I interviewed
Stephen Kenneth destiny bunnell the
second and the YouTube clip goes live in
50 minutes the title of the Steven
interview at the top of the hour is
destiny shot out of a cannon attacks
everyone and if you missed that
yesterday I think you are certainly
going to enjoy it because it is going to
be quite quite quite a publication for
sure the vegan villain s says where did
that go hold on a second the vegan
villain s says what do you think about
the people saying all lives matter in
regards to the black lives matter I'm
seeing it a lot on YouTube lately yeah I
think it's pretty dumb I mean it's like
listen when we had the Boston Marathon
bombing here in Boston and everybody was
about Boston strong it would have been
very dumb to show up and say what about
when Oklahoma City was bombed what about
what no ok it's not at the exclusion of
something else and so you have to
consider whether all lives matter should
be interpreted literally it's like well
of course all lives matter or do we need
to inspect whether there is a good faith
reason to say all lives matter instead
of black lives matter
here and you very quickly realized that
it doesn't really make sense listen when
we say coronavirus deaths it it's what's
happening with coronavirus is tragic do
we not care about flu deaths do we not
care about cancer deaths of course we do
of course we do but you you you you have
to just be logical and all lives matter
has essentially become a calling card
against the activism we're seeing no
reasonable person who is concerned about
police brutality and concerned about you
know how non white folks are treated in
certain situations I don't know any
people who would say I don't care about
all lives of course we care about all
lives it doesn't even need to be said
and you know it's look I don't even want
to it's it's ridiculous
Jeff Baker has signed up on YouTube
mm-hmm Jared at home says should should
put a late timer on these I should it
should start at the scheduled time and
then just count up to see how late she
is Waller is me says some all lives
matter people are ignorant and don't
have bad intentions most know exactly
what they're doing I agree
regular tactic of the right to sound
good while downplaying the real message
absolutely sabers man to 21 says if
Trump loses could he resign right before
Biden is sworn in to allow pence to
pardon him certainly could certainly
could Marika says Ingram Tucker Giuliani
are spinning black lives matter as bad
do you think people are still buying the
propaganda Trump poll numbers going down
at least yeah I mean listen um there are
fair critiques of black lives matter and
I've made many of them but the critiques
being made by the people you list marika
are not good-faith critiques and I think
that they are appealing to the choir so
to speak that watches Fox News but
widely speaking they're falling pretty
short let me say thank you to Angela
case angela is new member number five
today at join pakman.com Thank You
Angela I so appreciate your support and
I really I just appreciate everybody's
support everybody who's been supporting
through the website love you guys love
everybody
and reminder Tuesday June 16 8 p.m.
David Pakman show chess tournament all
are invited everybody
I don't care your skill level
everybody's welcome to participate and I
look forward to seeing you I will be
playing in the tournament I don't expect
to win but that's ok
I expect to enjoy it and I hope you'll
join me Tuesday night stun ever says
what a tool Trump wants to designate
antifa
as a terrorist organization the first
guy he identifies as such a terrorist is
the old man in Buffalo
yeah the Buffalo thing is crazy we've
got a big long clip coming out about it
today MK starr asks why are they always
late starting it says a lot I don't know
I genuinely don't know the answer missed
uh never ads has anyone figured out the
tire slashing and why I don't know much
about the tire slashing I wouldn't be
able to comment a photo says thoughts on
Georgia's primary disaster yesterday I
have a long clip coming out about that
it's already been recorded on today's
show so I will I will leave it to that I
try to not duplicate the content that's
already been recorded during the streams
just to avoid doing the same thing twice
JC says what should you do with a friend
who starts believing Trump and his
conspiracy theories just avoid politics
with them or engaged it's a very
personal decision it depends on the
exact circumstances it depends on how
confrontational you want to be depends
on what what type of relationship you
have it's really a call that you have to
make I can't I can't really tell you
it's it's a you know every situation is
different
mark Fillion says I'm a big believer on
life in the universe but seeing how
things are going it is not surprising
that et is not interested in making
contact yeah I know you're being sort of
tongue-in-cheek but there's a lot of
discussion of you know we may not have
heard from other intelligent life in the
universe if indeed it does exist because
we are just so primitive and it's like
what what kind of contact could we even
have we're still you know having people
kill
/ they believe the wrong religion or the
color of their skin is wrong and it
would not be surprising jordan y says
are you the one who messed up the Chris
Columbus statue in Boston no I was
streaming last night when it happened so
I have an alibi yeah I correct me if I'm
wrong but I believe that a Christopher
Columbus statue was decapitated here in
Boston last night let me see if I can
find it
Boston Columbus statue okay I've got it
right here
we're gonna pull it up oh by the way
thanks to Justine Cruz and Neil Pearson
who are new members 6 & 7 today at join
pakman.com let's look at this
Christopher Columbus thing I didn't even
read the details yet okay amid protests
Christopher Columbus statues take flak
in Richmond and Boston um okay let me
look at the Boston part that's not it
that's the Richmond part ok Boston
breaking overnight Christopher Columbus
statue in Boston's North End vandalized
and found beheaded it looks like from
what I'm seeing here it looks like the
head was like a screw-on or if it was a
discrete piece so it's not that it was
sawed off but it was just removed
apparently it was its own piece Boston
protesters managed to produce the more
shocking visual lopping off the head of
a Columbus statue in a park named in his
honor
Boston Police say they found the head
nearby after midnight Wednesday good I
have an alibi because I was
live-streaming when this happened
Boston member station WBUR notes this is
not the first time this particular
statue has been targeted with vandalism
five years ago the statue was dashed
with red paint and the words black lives
matter alright so there it is that that
happened
Toddie Jones says Charlamagne all black
people's sholde own guns should all
black people own guns I guess is the
question I mean listen I'm for reducing
the number of guns in this country but
there's no particular reason that the
white
people are the ones that should have
them so I you know I I'm about just
reducing the proliferation of firearms
in in total Mart Fillion says my point
exactly
Jamal Shu it a swift a Jamal haven't
seen you for a while says hi homie good
to see you
David gora says if bill bar needs an
aunty Fay leader I will gladly volunteer
to be the face of an Tifa since
technically all of us supports an Tifa
in the sense that we're against fascism
I think is the point that that you're
making and it is a point well made and
very much welcome thank you to Daniel
Sexton Daniel is new member number eight
today at join pakman.com we are standing
by for what is now a 20 minute overdue
press briefing from Donald Trump's press
secretary Kelly McKenna knee or McKenna
and Ana Annie and I think we're still
probably at least 10 minutes out because
a bunch of reporters just got up and
left but we will see it was scheduled
for 21 20 minutes ago thanks to Eduardo
Lido Costa who has sent a super chat as
well very much appreciate that
will there be exclusive twitch streams
upcoming again yeah I've been trying to
do an exclusive twitch stream at least
once a week lately yesterday during the
only on twitch stream I interviewed for
35 minutes
Stephen Kenneth destiny bonel the second
that will be published at 3:00 to
YouTube you would have already seen it
if you were watching on twitch last
night and I also played videos of Jimmy
from Philly I don't know if you guys
remember Jimmy from Philly we haven't
heard from him on the show for a little
bit but he actually did some videos
which he said it was okay for me to play
and he we played them yesterday and
people were very very stunned and also
oh people are asking for the Richard
Spencer meme I'll do it just since we
have time i rehabilitated
a Richard Spencer meme that someone made
for me I'll play this for you guys just
while we're waiting this is one of my
favorite things now just as a reminder
this does get loud so just watch your
speakers and especially if you are
listening in headphones just be prepared
because this does get a little bit loud
at a certain point volume warning
exactly take a look at this this is one
of my favorites will you denounced Adolf
Hitler I heard you don't denounce Adolf
Hitler when asked about that Adolf
National Socialism was it was a was a
disaster in the 20th century was a
pretty much a disaster yeah but do you
denounce the a fan of Adolf Hitler I'm
not gonna get I'm not gonna get I'm not
gonna play this game again throw out
historical figures and I denounce them I
mean do you denounce Stalin do you nan
ounce Pol Pot I mean look yeah
[Music]
I love that every time I see it it just
it just I don't know it's heartwarming
it's it says heartwarming as any video
can containing a literal white
nationalist can be I think is the way
that I would but I would put it let me
say a big thank you to Adam Kallenbach
who is new member number nine today at
join pakman.com but in any case the
point of all of that stuff I played and
mentioned oh I'll put the link to that
video people are asking for it I'm
putting it in the twitch chat and then
I'm putting it now in the YouTube chat
so everybody who wants that Richard
Spencer video can have it yeah it's it's
definitely evidence of a Giga Chad from
what I've read on Urban Dictionary I
think it's good ok
other super chats that are coming in
don't touch me I'm crazy says just as
many black folks buying guns at Cabela's
as white folks last time I went here in
Colorado I have no idea what Cabela's is
is rip City rapscallions says $10 says
Kayleigh blames black lives matter
protesters protests for the spike in
Corona cases yes I believe she will I
just don't know that she'll do it today
I think eventually she's going to do
that Oh Cabela's is a hunting store ok
yeah I so like what does a hunting store
offer guns bow and arrow I'm trying to
think what else a hunting store would
have bullets and arrows I guess boots
and and like camo gear deer urine type
stuff I'm guessing that you rub all over
yourself fishing lures camping related
elements bait ok Sporting Goods what
else would they even have rods deer yeah
I think that deer urine and like bird
calls and stuff right gloves and
sunglasses anti bug stuff sure they have
a lot of DEET and DEET related products
tents beef jerky right they probably
have those like rations like they're
technically food but only in the most
technical sense like it's
they just matter matter with caloric
matter as I would call it
thanks to Tron Buster and Jews onik once
I a friend of mine who drives a very
expensive car a German car said hey I
there's this there's an outdoors store
that carries a particular type of boot
that I want will you come with me to
this outdoors store and it's like it's
not a hunting store but it's just an
outdoor store it's not a chain it's a
local place and needless to say just the
presence of his you know V $800,000
German car in the parking lot at this
outdoors type place already generated
some some interesting looks and then
going in and stocking up on five pairs
of these boots it was a scene let's just
say it was not like the most comfortable
situation I've been in but then I was
like oh is this what people who really
go into hostile situations feel like
every single day just when they leave
their house maybe it's good for me to
feel like this momentarily okay no no
Hemi no I don't think German vehicles
have Hemis okay let's see here other
super oh wait hold on a lot of things
are happening at once let me say thank
you to to Sodor lasses for the support
over on Twitch I want to say thank you
to Spencer Canada Spencer is not only
new member number ten today but Spencer
has just signed up on my website for
what we call the big boy the four
hundred and eighty dollar a year
membership Spencer thank you thank you
so much I really do appreciate your
support we we I think under 1% of our
members get that what we called the big
boy and Spencer did indeed and I
appreciate it also want to say thanks to
Tanner Audia who is new member number 11
today Donna Grimes is new member number
12 and Jeffrey Corden er is new member
number 13 thank you I really do
appreciate that very much
ok other phone
sir wanting to get in here let's see
mark Fillion says I love that fact
Seinfeld says that always leave them
wanting more yes yes StuH never says
another $10 that Kayleigh blames black
lives matter for why she's late today
that I don't imagine cast says the
problem is all lives matter needs to be
said because of other minorities that
are also being harassed by police feel
left out especially those that can't
can't speak out I'm one yeah so one
thing that I would like to see is I the
the the amount of harassment of Latino
brown people in this country which has
an additional component I think that any
oppression Olympics is a loser's game I
want to be really clear about that but
there's an element to the harassment of
Latino folks by police that black folks
don't deal with which is suspicion
around immigration status and different
states have different rules there are
states with show me your papers laws and
states that ban show me your papers type
stuff but I certainly would if you said
to me is there any element that's not
prevalent enough in these protests it
would be the the targeted harassment of
Latino folks and you know as Mia as a
Hispanic immigrant myself who is white
who learned English very young I simply
don't experience that but many of my
friends and and many people that I know
acquaintances and others do experience
it and in any case I guess that that's
certainly something that I would you
know I think would be a valid addition
to the broader issues that are being
raised right now because the we're
talking about marginalization yes as
people are saying in in the chat okay
stoned the forbidden stone the forbidden
says I work at Bass Pro Cabela's when we
went into quarantine stay at home our
gun sales went up when protests start
gun sales went way up
yes Zachary foster says did you see
fowey and others Scot Gottlieb say they
were pretty confident in a vaccine by
the end of the year with an emergency
administration by September I did not
see that recently but yes I am aware
that that is a possible timeline that
has that has been proposed don't touch
me I'm crazy says I'm not trolling I'm
just giving information I thought would
add to the conversation okay beautiful
Anthony Sanchez says David I'm 50 and I
wish I had your hair thank you I
appreciate that yeah it's we're gonna do
it and as you can see I mean this is the
reason why it has to happen right I mean
this is not I'm pretty sure in
Mississippi at Alabama
you're not even allowed with this so
it's gonna have to I'm gonna have to
lower my chair if I want to keep my hair
like this and this is why the plan as of
right now is to get a haircut on it's
like Ace Ventura yeah I'm planning to
get a haircut on Friday couple other
thank-yous that I want to send out
actually I guess just one John fernell
is new member number 14 today at join
pakman.com thanks John and as I as I
mentioned at the top of the stream if
we're at 14 if we get to 25 new members
I will do the man bun tomorrow or
Thursday I'm sorry no tomorrow
tomorrow's the last opportunity if we
don't get a man bun
success by tomorrow I'm gonna have a
haircut before the next stream and
that's gonna be it that will that will
do it oh people asking about my only
fans there is no only fans but I am on
cameo you can find me on cameo now if
you want but I don't have an only fans
Daniel Daly says have you considered
turning alpha as Jesse Lee Petersen
suggested I have thought about it I
would love to be alpha someday it's
something to aspire to but I according
to Jesse Lee I need to be conservative
in order to do it and that doesn't seem
likely thank the Zachary Baker who
signed up on YouTube also zest the
African is asking what is Donald Trump's
best rant the orange is drivel or from
the standpoint of water yeah there's a
lot of good material there let me see if
I can find Trump oranges
Trump oranges I like let's see if we can
play that one oranges of the
investigation he was sitting at the
White House during that um Trump oranges
oh I'm having trouble finding it now
these are totally unrelated Trump
oranges investigation see if we can find
it here it is oh and take a look at the
oranges or the oranges of the
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation you look at the origin of
the investigation where it started how
it started who started it whether its
McCabe or Comey or a lot of them where
does it go how high up in the White
House that so that's oranges and then
here is Trump standpoint of water water
that's another good one
Florence this is a tough hurricane one
of the wettest we've ever seen from the
standpoint of water rarely have we had
an experience like it yeah so that's
from the standpoint of water I actually
think the best rant might be Trump dock
or Trump uncle nuclear weapons this
might be the best Trump rant let me see
if I've got it this one's actually tough
to find oh I'm not even finding it here
Trump John mit I know you guys know
which one I'm looking for but this isn't
it I'm failing to find it it's just it's
a stunning stunning rant about his uncle
now I'm having trouble oh wait a second
is this it nope that's not it yeah it
might be too old I'm getting all recent
clips oh wait a second listen oh this is
from April 2nd here he mentions him but
this isn't it
you can use a scarf oh god hold on a
second I think we're missing the press
briefing oh no we're not okay I don't
know where that came from I'm gonna
abandon that because that that just did
not go well
okay abort abort abort all right Oh hold
on
somebody is linking me to it let's see
Donald Trump on nuclear weapons maybe
this is it let's see well my comment is
it is 40 years at sportiness a lot but
not that much again I think I could just
say what I've already said the
relationship is strong we hope it's
going to get stronger I think we can do
a lot of things militarily also for
instance they're making a lot of weapons
I don't think this is weapons and so are
we
we just had seven hundred and sixteen
billion dollars approved military last
year now we're possibly going to do more
this year and between Russia and China
and us were all making hundreds of
billions of dollars worth of weapons
including nuclear which is ridiculous
and I would say that China will come
along and I would say Russia will come
along it doesn't really make sense that
we're all doing
I think we're the leader I think we're
always going to be the leader we have to
be the leader I think it's much better
if we all got together and we didn't
make these weapons okay yeah I think
this isn't it I just found it thanks to
somebody on twitch let me just see if
this has started yet this has okay I
think we have time for this this is
really worth watching if this is not
something you've seen before take a look
nuclear my uncle was a great professor
and scientist and engineer dr. John
Trump at MIT good good genes very good
James okay very soon the Wharton School
of Finance very good very smart you know
if you're a conservative Republican if I
were a liberal if like okay if I ran as
a liberal Democrat they would say I'm
one of the smartest people have where in
the world it's true but when you're a
conservative Republican they try do they
do a number that's why I always sort of
went to Wharton was a good student went
there went there did this built the four
yet I have to get my like credentials
all the time because we're at a little
disadvantage but you look at the nuclear
deal the thing that really bothers me it
would have been so easy and it's not as
important as these lives are nuclear is
so powerful
my uncle explained that to me many many
years ago the power and that was 35
years ago he would explain the power of
what's going to happen and he was right
who would have thought but when you look
at what's going on with the four
prisoners now it used to be three but
when it was three okay so you guys get
the picture it's just bizarre bizarre
ranting that is the clip that is the
infamous nuclear weapons clip thanks to
Simon B who is new member number 15
today very much appreciate that
Simon's signing up at join pakman.com
okay other super shots are coming in
let's see here okay Sharpie diesel says
what do you think about right wing
talking point that African Chiefs were
the ones to who sold the slaves versus
the British and Dutch roles in the slave
I've not seen that I couldn't comment
until I see that our ROM says what do
you think of Brian Tyler Coen I follow
him on Twitter I don't know much about
him other than his tweets I don't know
Amy gray says David now that you were
gardening are you composting as well or
have you thought about it I am NOT
currently composting I am interested in
adding some elements of composting I
would like to do the worm composting
because that seems to me to be the
preferred method but my girlfriend is
not thrilled with the idea of me by
she's trying to get worms away from her
and the idea of me buying worms and
having someone send me worms did not
strike her as particularly appealing so
I'm not currently composting but I have
been occasionally sprinkling some of my
spent coffee grounds in my garden not
too much because I know that you don't
want to acidify the soil too too much
but yeah for now I am compost list
compost list okay
toven a treaty says David Pakman Pet
Detective Ken Clive says in Los Angeles
I've had Latino friends get pulled over
because they're targeted for driving
modified cars I've been pulled over
because my car has custom suspension and
wheels no speeding and I look Latino
even though I'm from India yes that is
exactly what I'm referring to
Toddie Jones says should defund police
perhaps be delivered with a less
divisive euphemism yes check out my
videos from earlier this week on it
Gregory Washington has grabbed a
membership at you on YouTube we are
standing by now 38 minutes late 38
minutes late for Kaylee maggin Annie's
press briefing if you are just joining
us please remember that in 22 minutes my
35 minute wide-ranging interview /
therapy session with Stephen
Kenneth destiny banal ii is publishing
to youtube the best way always always
always always the best way to support
all of these things the streams during
the day the streams at night the youtube
clips the audio podcasts the chess
tournaments all this different stuff
is to get a membership on my website a
join pakman.com 15 people have done it
if we get to 25 we are going man-bun for
tomorrow stream I'm getting a haircut
Friday that's the last opportunity and
the coupon code that is in blue text
this is very important and if you're
color blind its 2020 now just so you
know that coupon code will save you 66%
off of the cost of a membership we have
quadrupled the bandwidth of our website
because it used to crash when I would
mention the website during these streams
so we upgraded it very powerfully and
very very strongly and everybody who
signs up gets a big THANK YOU from me
like Simon be Simon be was new member
number 15 so it's a it's just an
incredible thing that that is going on
and you don't have to do it of course we
are here for everybody ever all of our
content other than the bonus show is
always available for free and whether
it's you know a hype train or whatever
the case may be it's all happening all
the time and that is the message j-rod
at home says I hear Trump oranges his
oranges his based on their or engines is
this message orange sick oh boy I'm
gonna have to keep moving on that one
Beezus Christ that says I hope you all
understand that without demilitarization
of the public there will be no police
reform yeah this is an important thing
I've mentioned this a few times before
in order to demilitarize the police
you need to demilitarize the public we
have an amount of weapons just floating
around there that precludes
demilitarizing the police and at some
point that's going to have to be dealt
with gary Simpkins has signed up on
YouTube James Heller Poe says I prefer
the windmills rant that's a good one
yeah Sean M says thoughts on the parody
works of Randy rainbow excellent Randy
rainbows really really good Beezus
priced says the Kingdom of Benin an
empire sold people into slavery not
African Chiefs stay in school kids okay
Jim
Carter has subscribed on YouTube deep
space 90 says all are the black lives
matter protesters protests worth the
risk
considering kovat has killed over a
hundred thousand people but according to
the Washington Post only fifty fifteen
unarmed black people were killed by
police in 2019 it's not for me to say
it's not for me to say thanks to
Elizabeth not the Queen for upgrading
her membership Aramis says so you
upgraded the band girth of website
hosting yes the girth is much much
bigger now than it ever was on the
website thanks to shaun overton for
subscribing at join pakman.com Shawna's
new member number 16 if you are just
joining us this is not a replay we
really are 42 minutes late for the start
of this press briefing I want to welcome
everybody watching on twitch YouTube
Facebook and Twitter all roughly about
5,000 of you at this point in time
across all of these different platforms
very much appreciated we're expecting
that this will start any moment really
we have the press room much more filled
Monday Kaleigh only did about a two
minute presentation before switching to
questions and unpredictable what we are
going to see today I do want to say
thanks to rj roy 13 you our new twitch
subscriber number 6 6 6 which is ominous
sort of right i mean i don't know that
we want to stay on 666 too long but i do
appreciate your support
rj roy very very much thomas w says via
superjet who sounds more like a kazoo
shapiro or destiny I think Schapiro I
think Schapiro the Destiny interview
publishing at 3 he goes he attacks
everyone in this interview he attacked
Hasan [ __ ]
he attacked Kyle kolinsky he attacked
all sorts of different people but we
also I think got to talk about why
Steven seemed very manic during the
conversation I think it's a good
wide-ranging
it lasts about 35 minutes let me say
thanks to Rebecca Dawson who is new
member number 17 today
Gregory Washington is new member number
18 and Lynette Blake hey Lynette Lynette
is new member number 19 today at join
pakman.com let's see here G Egan and let
am have subscribed on YouTube
Chris Cod says David will we ever meet
your girlfriend do you simp well she is
a private person so I don't know I don't
even know what it means whether I simp
is there any kid can somebody tell me
maybe twitch is better equipped to tell
me this is the simple have any
connection to Giga chattery are there
are these two things connected in any
way we don't know okay they are inverse
oh geez simp means you are a chat oh my
god oh they're the same thing no they're
polar opposites okay it seems Giga chat
is better Giga Chad seems better than
simple I don't know
okay thanks dude don't touch me I'm
crazy and MOT chic for subscribing on
YouTube nasty questions says smash the
like button very strongly yeah listen I
know we joke around about memberships
and all of that stuff but I don't need
you to send me any money but if you are
watching on twitch please do follow me
on Twitch it's free it's really easy and
we're trying to get to 50,000 twitch
followers if you're watching on youtube
hit that like button hit that subscribe
button these things are all free they
cost nothing the ban banning people is
free which is why we do it so much now
I'm kidding we don't ban too many people
but yeah no but it follows and all of
that I don't need anybody you know we're
here for free and it's all it's all
happening and people absolutely love it
okay I am told that we are very very
close we are dangerously close to the
start of today's press briefing with
Kaylee Mac and Annie Joel the wiz ik or
Dow is ik is new member number 20 on my
website join pakman.com I also want to
say thanks to Christopher Kali who is
new member number 21 today and Jacob
happy
is new member number two we're getting
very close to 25 at which point I will
be committed to wearing a man bun
tomorrow during my stream which I'm kind
of regretting but I guess I'm gonna do
it I I don't know for people asking if a
man bun is Giga Chad or not
I just I'm just not sure okay
over/under on duration today oh it looks
like things are about to happen let's
see here I think that this will be 22
minutes in total today we will see we
have a slow zoom and a standing
photographer so I'm anticipating that
this may start ok people saying 19
minutes I think it'll go longer than 22
that's my guess as of right now and here
we go oh no we don't paperwork is being
handed out okay 17 minutes some folks
are saying yeah it's it's are very hard
to predict these have been Verdi's are
some of these shortest press briefings
that we've seen generally in in recent
political history Greg Oliver senior
says do you think there will be violent
protests when Trump loses I think if
it's close and Trump says it was rigged
in some way I believe that there will be
violent protests yeah and I'm genuinely
concerned about that okay oh okay it
looks like we're getting close so I'm in
a mute here or we are muted and we're
going to pick up the oh no this is like
way behind oh my goodness
alright now so we'll go back to the Fox
News stream for now the color seems
better on the fox news stream as well to
be perfectly frank yeah I do worry about
violent protests again I think if Trump
gets crushed by Biden by anything close
to how much he's losing by right now in
the polls I think it'll really deflate a
lot of the trumpets where they may just
not want to be seen for four years but I
think that there could be protests if
it's close all right here we go
so I'm sorry we are very late you guys
I'm sorry to keep you waiting I was
working with the President on something
and he wanted me to hand this out to you
all and I have it here so I want to read
it to the American public directly from
the president it has been suggested that
we should rename as many as ten of our
legendary military bases such as Fort
Bragg in North Carolina oh my god in
Texas who cares bidding in Georgia and a
list goes on these monumental and very
powerful bases have become part of a
great American heritage in a history of
winning victory and freedom the United
States of America countries deployed our
heroes here and won two world wars
110,000 dead my administration will not
even consider the renaming of these
magnificent wave old military
installations our history as the
greatest nation in the world will not be
tampered with respect our military
amia that was directly from the
president we spent some time working on
that and I wanted to deliver that to
spent time working also I wanted to take
us through few other things relating to
the corona virus first the corona virus
task force briefing was held yesterday I
was in it there was some very good news
that I'd like to share with you I don't
know if you all saw there were two
studies that came out very strong
studies in the journal Nature and in
Europe which had a very similar epidemic
profile to the United States 3.1 million
lives were saved due to mitigation and
the efforts taken by the European
government also thanks to us dr. Burks
noted to me she sent this to me just
before I walked out here she said it
suggests that the United States also
prevented over 3 million deaths thanks
to the efforts of President Trump and
the American people it was actually
think another study found that the shut
down efforts prevented 50 million
additional coronavirus cases so those
are two very encouraging studies
underscoring the work of the American
people Trump was supportive of
protesters demanding things be opened
and now now she's taking credit for
Trump for closing understand that their
conclusions they suggest that the
aggressive and unprecedented shutdowns
were effective at halting the
exponential spread of the novel
coronavirus
which Trump's Washington Post
for that good reporting the department
of agriculture secretary sonny perdue
also had some very good news and the
task force briefing i was at yesterday
america's meatpacking facilities at one
time it looks like they were going to
need to close that was unacceptable to
the administration so we took action the
coronavirus task force took action and
now i'm pleased to report that these
meatpacking facilities are operating at
ninety five percent capacity compared to
twenty nineteen we have beef operating
at ninety eight percent capacity pork
and ninety five percent in poultry at
ninety eight percent throughout
America's extraordinary efforts to slow
the spread president Trump ensured that
the meat supply chain stayed functional
and robust by directing these
meatpacking facilities to safely operate
in accordance with the CDC and OSHA
guidelines right
his efforts secured America's continual
access to a steadies food supply chain
and then finally and very importantly I
have some great data points to share on
coronavirus testing capacity and
minority communities animal brett dois
shared this with me yesterday and last
night as well he said that when we look
at testing sites president Trump's
public-private partnership yeah with
retail companies has proven quite
successful testing sites are operating
in 49 states with 70% of these sites
located in communities with moderate to
high so it's funny how they haven't
talked about coronavirus for like a
month and now they just come out and
basically repeat the exact same stuff
they were saying a month ago now we have
a hundred and ten thousand dead Florida
Texas Arizona are exploding it's it's
like a month has just gone like
nothing's changed what nation they
provide care to one in five of those
uninsured one in five and rural
Americans one in five of one in three of
individuals below the poverty line and
more than 1.3 million homeless men and
women I mean nearly a million migrant
agricultural workers 92 percent of these
FQHCs now offer Cova tests and we've
awarded them five hundred eighty three
million dollars to a thousand three
hundred eighty five of these facilities
and finally finally a problem promise my
last announcement the HHS office of
minority health issued a competitive
funding opportunity to build a strategic
network of now
state/territory tribal local and
community-based organizations
he doesn't even know what she's reading
like she's not parsing the grammar of
what she's reading it's bizarre
minorities and this this announcement
this network is scheduled to be awarded
at the end of June and is expected to
reach at least 40 million individuals
from racial and ethnic minorities these
updates I was told by bread flour were
received very well at the Senate
hearings oh yeah and we thank the vice
president Mike Pence for doing an
amazing job leading our coronavirus task
force into President Trump who is led by
the way when was the last time we saw
Pence and his up to by the way what's
going on with Project airbridge have 72
flights been scheduled questions about
an interaction and a video clip e salt
and the president has the right to ask
those questions right the president does
not regret standing up for law
enforcement men and women across this
country there really drop let me say
this and just give you a little bit
about the mindset behind the president's
tweet look we're living in a moment on
the mind zone it seems to be reflexively
anti police officer and it's
unacceptable to the President and this
tweet that he sent out he was imagining
and owning it faced with historic police
beatings of people siding with those in
the position of power the ones with the
guns the night sticks the pepper spray
that imagine what maybe could this
strategically help Trump in some way
it's very hard to imagine to have fast
before he tweets anything wrong as the
president
see the president didn't have facts
before he tweeted out that undergirded
his class was the asking question no not
at all I won't acknowledge that because
look you had let's contrast this to the
George Floyd situation which that
horrific video that we all saw every
single police officer that I saw across
the country came out and said this is an
inexcusable action guys it wasn't
baseless it was based on than Oh a and
report from a former Sputnik
propagandist guys it was that that those
were that was the factual basis
president says those law enforcement
officers have a right to be heard john
said anything justifies that 75 year old
man being pushed down to the ground we
also the president does not condone
violence he wants to see the appropriate
amount of police force used in any given
situation but he believes that the
officers have a right to be heard his
brother is here testifying as the White
House invited him here
the president has repeatedly
acknowledged George Floyd his passing
the egregious enough that atrocity and
has called the family by phone that's a
night he did last week yes the president
has got an event tomorrow in Dallas and
a church in which he'll meet with faith
leaders he'll also neighbor law
enforcement officials small business
owners the theme is a plan for holistic
revitalization named by the way officers
have a right to be heard yeah the 75
year old protester Martin Gugino
couldn't be heard because he was
critical in a hospital for the last week
the president has spent the last 10 days
quietly and diligently working on
proposals to address the issues that the
protesters have raised across the
country humbly with intimate issues and
that body of work I'm told is reaching
its final edits and we hope to produce
it for you in the coming days I can't
promise Michael tomorrow but in the
coming days we look to deliver that
tomorrow will be about will it be a
listening session as he had on Monday
with law enforcement letter listen might
there actually be some concrete policy
yeah we'll be around it will be a round
table I'm much like what you saw with
law enforcement Oh propaganda gotta stay
on that theme for a second in terms of
reform ideas that the president could
support she's not getting some in the
house Senate Republicans led by Tim
Scott were working on others things like
banning chokeholds banning no not
Lawrence independent process to
investigate misconduct could the
president support issues like that so
again don't wanna get ahead of the
announcements what I would say is each
issues being looked at as to what would
make a difference every thing that
you've suggested has certain
ramifications so he asked to look at
each of these in great detail as he's
done over the last few days and I would
just note one thing that AG Barr said
was that in the democrat bill they
talked about needing to reduce immunity
to go after bad cops but that would
result in police pulling back so that is
one thing that is a non-starter don't we
need that a red line for the president
that's a non-starter in the democrat
legislation yes John
institutional racism in this country he
believes there are embracing answer this
question I think this is the fourth time
I've been asked it and I've said each
and every time there are injustice is
that we have seen clearly that tape of
George Floyd was inexcusable
gut-wrenching difficult to watch it was
really a beautiful funeral yesterday all
the great testimonies to his life we
recognize those and justices Sandra
bland another example but this president
knows fundamentally that most police
officers in this country are good no 150
men and women that have been injured the
point is there's a few bad officers
create a structure that is problematic
nobody nobody's denying that most police
officers are good that is the best right
and that is our domestic heroes to
fundamentally change the way law
enforcement has done in this country to
make fundamental changes so that there
isn't the kind of disparities that we
see well the president's looking at
various proposals and I would say this
president has done a whole lot more than
Democrats have ever done when it comes
to rectifying and justices that's a lot
where you had the crime bill of the
night struck which created great racial
disparities in our justice system and
president Trump rectified some of those
with the first step back so how many new
ones now create I mean he's shown that
and he recognizes and justices and acts
promptly when he sees them yes
[Music]
so I haven't spoken to him on that
specific Horseman um he does as I noted
at the top of this briefing fervently
stand against the renaming of our forts
these great American fortresses a
question Hayley literally some of these
men and women who lost their lives as
they went out - yeah just not even
remotely to understand a rock and all
across this world to win world wars on
behalf of freedom a lot of times the
very last place they saw was one of
these forts another question to suggest
that these forts were somehow inherently
racist and there needed to change is a
complete disrespect to the men and women
or the last was America before they went
overseas and lost their lives for these
forts so America wanted to review the
plain case so the Justice Department
engaged in conduct to benefit a
political ally of the president this is
why the government dismissed the charges
what is the White House reaction I've
got the first I'm hearing about I'd
point you to DOJ on that Jeff
congresswoman Louise Cheney have
criticized the president's decision to
reduce the number of US troops in
Germany some saying that they will
enrolled in a Russia if we if the United
States does that did the president make
that decision to punish Chancellor
Merkel for deciding not to come to the
g7 in June okay I have no announcements
on that front and he never makes
decisions to punish certain world world
leaders he acts and the gentleman fell
harder than he was pushed
yes how is how does that work in terms
of physics yes report he saw he has a
right to ask those questions and where
he stands question with law enforcement
he was making no judgments not condoning
violence not saying what happened in
this I think what Jeff Mason is asking
is the guy fell faster than simply
freefall the some other force had to
have been acting on him in the sense of
gravity and from the standpoint of
mechanical physics yeah it's a good
question he met on a potential face for
policy last week it was a very promising
discussion with his economic advisors
gone that's in the works as to when and
if we see that but it is a topic of
discussion he was encouraged by the jobs
report we were supposed to leave lose
7.5 million jobs we ended up gaining 2.5
million a swing by 10 million it was
described to me as one of the by one
famed economist as one of the worst
miscalculations of economists in history
to be off by 10 million that's the size
of Michigan so the presidents encouraged
because what we're seeing is a belief in
the Trump economy and the Trump
presidency
what we're seeing is the markets or
we're seeing that SNP have its best
50-day track record in history because
they believe in a president that has
free-market policies that got us to the
hottest economy try these three markets
boom yes
to be elevated for years and also this
week we heard from the National Bureau
of economics research saying that the
u.s. officially entered a recession what
is the we believe that next month's job
jobs report will be robust the president
has been clear that q4 he expects it q3
to be a transition period q4 to be
robust and next year to be a very hot
year and I would notice they were off by
10 million that's not too good so I'd go
back and look at some of the models that
were often on how extraordinary the jobs
report was last time including 300,000
new jobs for black Americans yes thank
you so much the president met with Mitch
McConnell today we understand what that
discussion was about things so I have no
announcements on that front
those were his private meetings so no
announcements out of that Jonathan's
question you know a lot of people are
concerned that there is you mentioned
justice disparities there's a lot of
concern of some Americans that police
officers treat black individuals and
people of color differently than white
individuals does the president share
those specific concerns here's what he's
concerned about he's concerned about
what the and I've told you he's
addressed in justices with Sandra bland
and George Floyd and has repeatedly
acknowledged that but here is in
addition to that his concern put very
well by New York's Police Benevolent
Association president Mike O'Mara our
legislators are failing us our press is
vilifying us he's saying us as police
officers stop treating us like animals
and thugs we've been vilified and it's
disgusting when you have a sitting
congressman Ilhan Omar calling cops
cancer what do you think that leads to
the AP reported on a shooting in front
of a police department today in
California
let's stop vilifying our officers let's
recognize injustice where we see it but
recognize all of us in here are safe
because of our police officers doing
their job each and every day
Americans that people of color are not
treated the same by police and that is
what many of the protests have been
about this line of dust Amir this year
those specific concerns the President
believes most of our police officers are
good hard-working men and women like
David Dorn
who was killed among these riots like
Patrick Underwood who was killed among
these riots those are our police
officers they are best they are our
brightest they're absolute places that
places of injustice we're addressing
those we're looking at legislative
proposals and Yeo's and you know what
ultimately is determine we'll see in the
coming days as to what will work as a
policy prescription but stop vilifying
our officers because they deserve better
than that they're out there they're
working hard 750 injured just in the
last week and a half and we need to
recognize that yes is the president
disappointed that more Republicans have
not lined up to support the questions he
asked to choose your characterization
about as many people also characterize
it as a conspiracy theory and secondly
has the president reached out either to
the injured gentleman or to the police
officers involved
no um so first of all President Trump I
would say he's not focused on what
Republicans are saying or not saying on
the hill he's focused on making changes
as I said he's been diligently hard at
work the last 10 days and that is where
his focus squarely lies at the moment
yes and as he reached out to other the
not that I'm aware of no not that I'm
aware hello
you started this briefing reading off
some statistics about successive
mitigation efforts on the spread of
Kovac but her glasses spike in cases in
more than a dozen states and increased
hospitalizations and a lot of those as
well yeah so on many public health
experts attribute these spikes to
Memorial Day weekend gatherings and
other aspects of the reopening process
before these mass protests so why is
President Trump continuing to urge
reopening giving given this trend and
should we be slowing down a little bit
on the reopening process as we see cases
like first let me know as it pertains to
Memorial Day a week ago today the vice
president's team told me I was an int
asked force that day but that it was
said that in fact that there was no
linkage to Memorial Day as being some
point of spurring wild outbreaks and
rises across the nation pence told her
that someone told him that Memorial Day
was fine got it is that in general April
averaged out to be about 30,000 cases a
day May was about 25,000 cases a day
currently we're at around 20,000 cases a
day and you've got to look in a nuanced
way at each of these states like for
instance Texas is one of the places
where they're saying we're seeing a
steady slow not a huge rise but part of
its in and due to the fact that they're
testing and long-term care facilities
and in prisons and the more testing you
do the more cases you identify so that's
a bit of the testing rate in Texas is
not very high but then explain Arizona
explain Florida explain Georgia
precautions is he going to be taking in
his rallies for this
we have no rallies and now it's just yet
you're right about the two-week timeline
that was put forward but we will ensure
that everyone who goes is safe but no
specific announcements on that front and
I would direct you to the campaign for
more information on that yes yes nice
taking my question Owen Jensen with EWTN
news we've seen thousands of people in
the streets protesting exercising their
constitutional right those of course
doing it peacefully at the same time
churches in many cases told to limit
their gatherings in some cases to town
are no more does the president see a
double standard there constitutionally
speaking and if their absolute double
standards that we've seen and that's why
justice that's what we call it at all a
task force if you will or a group to
look at civil liberties on eyes during
coronavirus shutdowns you know I read
about one case where you had allowance
of outside gathering and protest but in
door I really saw her answer is trash
and I'm gonna mute it briefly understand
that just during this press briefing she
gave Trump credit for shutdowns which
Trump regularly opposed by supporting
people protesting against the shutdowns
and then now again is talking about the
fact that the shutdowns were a problem
despite earlier saying we are winning
because Trump shut things down which of
course he didn't actually do it was
really governors like are you I hope you
guys are following the talking out of
not even two sides of her mouth out of
four four sides of her mouth at the same
time it reopened a church down the road
for me so I think he gave a lot of
courage to the faith community to reopen
to do so safely and who we are I think
four weeks later and we haven't been
hearing about you know rampant outbreaks
and places of worship the First
Amendment's a beautiful thank you you
are doing all right to go to church or
mosque or synagogue yes very nice still
covered
the presidency uh concert so far about
November the Kobe situation and whether
people are going to be afraid to go to
polls or whether it's going to be a lot
of delays because of the comment he
recently said it's a long way off I
think meaning the pandemic would have
died out by then essentially but given
that it hasn't actually gone away if
people are still dying every day and
there are some spikes and it's not that
far away five months
are any measures being taken at all to
now to guarantee that this election is
going to go smoothly and everybody wants
the bug yeah well I you know I've not
seen much criticism of the protest and
socially distance and mitigation efforts
I think there's a way to safely vote if
you can safely protest and that's what
the president would like to see there's
a way to safely vote there's a way to
safely go to church and you're asking a
hypothetical about something five months
from now at a time ironically on when
the media hasn't expressed much outrage
about a lack of mitigation efforts taken
by some of the protesters I hope you
guys noticed that those things are
totally unrelated is the president
concerned the protest could lead to
another outbreak of coronavirus and a
second question yes very short say that
he
does not believe that death toll and
coronavirus case figures show some
country thus he trusts the figure from
Brazil means the White House concerned
that the Brazilian government is hiding
information about Covina 19 so I haven't
spoken to him about the Brazil numbers
but I have heard him on several cases
probably at least five mention that he'd
seen what's going on in Brazil and he
was hurt to see how many people have
been affected by Cova down there so yeah
as mentioned Brazil specifically I
believe he even sent some ventilators to
Brazil because we had such an overflow
of ventilators here because America
really under the leadership of President
Trump snapped into action and delivered
so I would just note that the rapid
acceleration in that result is the
president concerned the protests could
lead to another outbreak
another monitor still wouldn't happen
you know right now we're encouraged to
see that cases have declined month over
month but you know the Vice President as
I walked out here said the task force is
well aware of monitoring individual
situations in particular States Niels
Haley thank you thank you going back to
where you started with the statement
about reading the military bases if
Congress were to send over verse say the
defense off
with language that were to remain one of
these bases for someone who say was a
general who won the Civil War would the
president veto the Defense Authorization
the president will not be signing
legislation that renames America's forts
it's important to note you know Fort
Bragg for example it's one of the
largest military installations it's home
to tens of thousands of brave American
soldiers and when you think of Fort
Bragg we think of the brave soldiers
that deployed from there we think of
five World War two Airborne Division's
82nd the 101st the 11th the 13th and the
17th all trained at Fort Bragg the 555th
Parachute Infantry Battalion this was
the first black parachute battalion
trained this fort we must recognize the
sacrifices made by these men and women
some of whom saw Fort Bragg for the last
time before they went overseas and we've
got to think she wrote humanitarian
option operations like in Hurricane
Katrina in the earthquake in Haiti we've
got to honor what has happened there not
rename it so that is an absolute
non-starter for the President and I
would also no question of that General
David Petraeus is one of those people
who went through Fort Bragg a number of
times even though his first command was
at the
but for Campbell Kentucky he penned a
quite lengthy and detailed editorial
about the reasons why those spaces
should be renamed saying it's ironic
that American soldiers and Marines are
being trained and phases name for people
who fought against the Union back in the
Civil War that many of the it is the
long these bases are named we're leaders
held in questionable regard but who were
elevated during the Lost Cause movement
because obviously they no I did not live
in a country to which Braxton Bragg
Henry L banger robert e lee can serve as
an inspiration what does the White House
say to that not for me Bragg is known
for the heroes within it that train
there that deployed from there and it's
an insult to say to the men and women
who left there the last thing they saw I
think this is all a distraction it would
actually be worse if people really cared
that much about whether Fort Bragg
remains Fort Bragg in the midst of a
hundred and ten thousand dead and
everything else that we're dealing with
so it's a distraction and it would be
even worse if this actually became like
the big issue I'm here I'm told that no
longer can you find on HBO and Gone with
the Wind because somehow that oh no how
offensive where do you draw the line is
it should George Washington and Thomas
Jefferson and James Madison refused
Monday history
what about FDR and because of internment
camps you know he should he be erased
from history or Lyndon Johnson who has a
history of documented racist statements
and finally with all people that are
alleged by the media to be
segregationist NBC tells us Joe Biden
didn't just compromise with
segregationists he fought for their
causes in schools experts say CNN tells
us letters from Joe Biden reveal oh yeah
tells us that Biden's tough talk on 1970
schools desegregation plans could get
him new scrutiny and there are several
more that that's where that came from so
I'll leave you with the questions any of
you white and welcome center thanks very
much guys
I think my IQ went from 97 to 95 during
that press briefing I think it's really
a big big big problem oh my god these
are these have gotten dramatically worse
I mean I don't know I don't even I think
we're gonna rap because I'm just I just
what could I possibly say it's it's
trash it's absolute in total trash
thanks for joining me guys
I I'll be back soon we did hit 25 new
members by the way so I will do the the
man bun on the next stream appreciate it
see you guys soon
you